Now that we have some of the core concepts down, let's talk about the difference between a controller and a pawn class inside of Unreal Engine.
So controller and pawn classes are both controller classes.
So a player controller takes input directly from something physical such as a controller or a keyboard or mouse.
It takes input that the player is trying to communicate from the physical world into the digital world.
And this can be a magnitude of input devices as well. You see all different kinds of peripherals being used inside of Unreal Engine, so it doesn't have to be a controller or a keyboard.
But for this instance we'll keep it more straightforward as these are the more typical input devices.
An AI controller then mimics inputs like a player controller.
So again because it's AI it will just mimic that input as if it was a player controller.
And then when we're thinking about possession, controllers can possess anything from a pawn class and its children.
So it's useful to think about this concept at the bottom here. The player is like a spirit that controls an avatar.
So the player is a controller, the player is wanting to input into this world in some way.
So they're the spirit and they've not embodied anything yet.
And then when we possess something which needs to inherit from a pawn class, again going back to those core concepts of inheriting from different parent classes.
If something is from a pawn class it means it can accept this possession and it knows how to react to that.
And so when something is possessed the input then passes through the player controller directly into the controlled pawn.
When we're talking about the pawn class we get input from the controller.
So the user or the player has input something from the controller and now it's come down through into the pawn.
So the controller passes input from the user or AI into the pawn and then the pawn will then create maybe some kind of movement or it'll react to the input that has been provided to it.
A character class is more advanced movement. A character class will have capsule components, they may have some form of skeletal mesh components so they can move and react to that input and probably animate in some way.
So generally all characters, monsters, vehicles etc derive from the pawn class.
So hopefully that gives you a good overview about how that logic flows from when you press a button or click a mouse button and then get something to react in the world.